even if sentence her to finish
college oh my God I can't do it stick
around I want to thank our sponsor
farity our guys farity is a family brand
founded by Alex his wife Carrie and his
twin brother Mike these dudes are
amazing the whole family is amazing the
channels their love of the beach
lifestyle into clothing for life's
greatest moment fairity crafts clothes
that feel as good as the day at the
Beach and they're backed by their
guarantee of quality so farity is giving
all dumb people Town listeners an
amazing deal 20% off your order head to
farity brand.com
DPT use the code DPT at checkout for 20%
off your order that's
ferty brand.com
DPT jamesallen.com is the fastest
growing online retailer of engagement
rings and Diamond jewelry and they've
already been a part of over 200,000
engagements across the world is yours
next yeah get 25% off your order when
you go to jamesallen.com and use the
code dpj that's code DPT at
jamesallen.com for 25% off
jamesallen.com hey Tes welcome to
another episode of Dum people Town
population you population Watts Regal Q
watts is it a q in the middle yeah
there's a q q original I'm part of the Q
I am part of the Q
contingency but the Q is just a line
it's a cue it's a q yeah yeah right of
course yeah English yeah like Americans
out there line the beginning was Q so Q
was fast forward on some old tape equ Q
It Forward you mean cu cu forward it yes
pool get it ready but what is how do you
spell a line in England Q that's a yeah
they don't have the word line we it's an
American word god get or they stand
online stand online we were standing
online I will not abide that Coast that
will not I will not stand get in que and
stand online yeah stand online get in
que well the world's getting dumber and
I'm so happy that you're here to break
it down with us re thanks I love it so
we get stories sent To Us by our friends
and fans they're friends I let's be
honest they're family the first one s
I'm going to jump into one right away we
used to be that Dan did all the stories
and now we each take one so this is
really fun buckle up
we're going to talk about lay talk about
you talk about your new book in a little
bit but let's get into this which was a
story sent by carlen
mcder she Caren phenomenal name and a
phenomenal she s she's like a Stringer
she sends us our stories you ready for
this yeah headline woman faked
kidnapping to conceal the fact that she
dropped out of college whoa this is
that's uh that sounds very likely yeah
and also I'm like you're showing a lot
of initiative to fake this she should
get some college credits for the faking
of the kidnapping and then that should
complete the collegeology experiment or
she should you know like be involved in
planning a heist of a lot of forethought
P yes if she writes a patty patty
Heist Patty Heist it's a Patty Heist
Patty so she's a Patty Hearst type
person who plans Heist Heist she's Patty
Heist what if Patty
Heist that's not it that's not it Heist
was Barber who stole a
girl what if she writes like a 200 Page
Ransom note oh you think she has to do a
Manifesto to me what if she writes about
her whole experience faking the
kidnapping and turns it into like the
psych Department it's like there you go
at the end she's like Tada my you're
welcome yeah this was immersive project
in college ever yeah a woman has been
arrested arrested why should she have I
guess the resour yeah you can't F it's
just you even if it's you're the only
one involved you still get arrested
that's right is anyone looking for me
half of you gets
arrested what did you do to yourself I
told myself I was kidnapped visi
yourself aren't we all kidnapped that's
how that's who kidnapped you am I right
hopefully Nicole
kidnapped right hey heartbe break feels
good in a place like a woman has been
arrested for allegedly trying to fake
her own abduction in a bid to conceal
the fact that she dropped out of college
and was not going to graduate as a
student of course she wouldn't have
graduated as a student what would she
have graduated gr as a monk
fish which is the lobster of fish uh
Khloe Stein 23 from Pennsylvania in the
US was arrested on Tuesday May 2nd is
that a bell and Sebastian song chlo
Stein
CH Stein feels like it now seor Stein oh
sorry great
song hman uh falsely reporting a crime
that did not happen obstructing the
administration of Law and disorderly
conduct what's the disorderly conduct
there she unruly fight was kid
okay drk let her talk let her talk she's
drunk she feels disorder problem with
that yeah you
got don't break that stuff hold her back
let her tell all
order her a drink let her sit down oh
she's [__] on your desk David
[__] on your desk you're not going
to graduate as a student acting like
that I'll graduate in time my no she
can't we're hearing from the school you
can't we're hearing from the I'm I'm
getting now a real time earpiece to
the my ear someone just handed me hot
hot off the pr the school is on the line
the school is on the
line miss a fact was last heard on
Monday evening when she texted her
boyfriend while driving home from work
saying she was being pulled over by
police officer officers later heard from
her family who said they found the
vehicle Volkswagen Beetle abandoned why'
she do this to them wa so she roped her
boyfriend into he doesn't know that's a
problem FAL can I just tell her she's
putting way too much pressure on herself
I agree she can't tell her boyfriend
that she want by the way the amount of
thought going into this do your homework
or go to class or drop out use the all
of this energy and initiative to go do
something you love and extra money yeah
two people I know who dropped out
College are two of the smartest people I
know so like be that person be that guy
reveal be the Dropout you hope to see in
the world exactly your parents are fault
they put so much pressure on that you
have to graduate in order to be a whole
person and not only do you have to
graduate you have to graduate as a
student it's so hard to do this hard to
do me come there's too many expectations
on children today we know a lot of this
woman we're over programming State
Police Trooper Steve lmani yep said in a
news Steve lmani driver lmani come on
down to Steve lmani Ford where if you
don't get a deal we give you a deal you
don't get a
deal going to personally make sure you
get a I'll make you off always a
different type of car here here's Steve
lman Ford you can go down to get this
beautiful Chevy Trailblazer it's like
you're a for Subaru has still got drinks
in the drink holder you got beagle tail
on do you know how to clean blood
yourself you're going to love this geom
Metro he love chrysa we love lasers how
about a chrys lasers chry laser GE geot
tracker geom Metro and a
geostorm all three for three what did
Larry spon say revealed that she was
safe and well at home in Janette about
30 mil south of Pittsburgh who in
Janette
huhan she's an in Janette Miss
reportedly told office she was pulled
over and abducted by an unknown male who
posed as a police officer so now she's
kind of like roping the police somewhat
police it was you guys she's like
Dorothy you were there and you were
there so she's saying I was kidnapped by
a person pretending to be a police
officer right after I told my boyfriend
I sorry I need I'm getting pulled over
yeah she claimed he had arm she was St
she oh my God and taken to various
location in the area but before she was
found police had received a call from
Penn State University officials who said
she was not in an enroll she was not an
enrolled student contrary to new
that described her as a senior so this
is going to come out well cuz she said
it in news reports I'm a senior and then
they go not here we'll check on that you
know what you need to do interesting
watch every episode of the show alone so
that you get enough knowledge of to
maybe live survive for 5 to 6 hours
outside exactly then go out into the
woods with your all your stuff that you
secretly bought with cash right live
there for hopefully a month but even a
week yeah mhm you come back stumbling
out you're going to have to hi all that
stuff and you can't pollute so you're
going to need to come get that later you
come stumbling out they'll go oh my God
you've been gone where the hell you're
like I don't know I don't know what
happened to me I just walked into the
woods and then no don't ever include
anybody else I I tried to go for a walk
and then I just got lost disoriented
whatever right you still might get rung
up if they really had a whole people you
claim disorientation I feel like who's
going to who can arated dropped out of
college and they're going we don't care
about that you're back you're back
you're back I mean maybe she said you
know she could say something like well
you know I instead of orientation I went
to disorient student disorientation and
I just got I really went there I
actually did it maybe I should have got
into drama yeah maybe you wanted me to
commit to things no it's maybe I
shouldn't have gone to the
disorientation and gone to the
orientation Mr Lani said during the
course of that phone call the one phone
call to Penn State University we like
she's not a senior mhm we found out that
and Penn State is also like we not don't
pull us into we had enough [__] to deal
with Jerry sesy ruined our found out I
might bleep his name that she had not
been attending college for quite some
time almost at a the point where it's
over a year maybe two and graduation was
right around the corner that really led
us in the direction that at any point of
time there was no police interaction
there was no pullover none of that
happened so as soon as they're like
she's not a senior they're like she this
didn't happen you know what I want to go
back and I want to give her credit for
not pulling her boyfriend into this lie
right he's completely innocent and that
was kind of her I'll meet you on the
other side so she
cares like I'm not taking anybody else
down with me they got to at least
consider that in the trial agree love
consider compassion consider love Penn
State said she was last enrolled in 2018
at Penn State fet God she's been keeping
this L for a while 15 miles from
Pittsburgh when she was confronted about
the evidence she quote admitted that she
had fabricated all the information
pertaining to the incident the like so
she folded
like you know people in movies and stuff
can hold up the RO no no they go excuse
me ma'am are you I lied about
everything plan is bad if you if it can
if it all hinges on you not getting
asked about man we just got off the
phone with I made it all up can you just
sentence me and we and can I be in jail
and it be all
over she walks speedy trial right speedy
trial technically I'm already dely
Speedy Delivery speedy trial the fact of
not going to school apparently for so
long and maybe disappointing was people
was the reason behind it but she was
never in danger and her you know said at
no point she you you haven't gotten in
all I want for this is I feel like the
person who just didn't understand it's
okay to admit mistakes or that you need
something different in your life she was
worried about pressure and letting
people down I want this it it was very
wrong I hope it's all community service
just do something like like like we
don't need you're not going to find even
they sentence her to finish college oh
my God I can't do it I can't do it you
have to that's your that is your and
it's paid for like for with grants right
yes or or so she's actually better off
yeah she's like yeah she's better off
having done the crime although I bet you
they'll be like she'll well it's
possible that she could do like a kind
of like add this element this feature
like yes she lied about everything but
there's like footage of a van that is
parked like maybe 200 ft away and there
was a guy that was actually abducting
people so she it she by like hundreds
ofet two seconds if you are that guy
kidnap her now yeah yeah get her
nobody's going to believe her oh
somebody forgot to go to the grocery
store and then we'll have you on
kidnapping today yes kidnapping Friday I
mean it prompted fear in the community
who thought there was an abductor at
large so now she's responsible for fear
in the community oh okay okay fear in
the community great band fear in the
community for panic at The District open
for panic of the
district it is that is exactly what I
thought that
is% are you afraid yet in the community
theck the theck is song I'm going
nowhere round and round this sounds like
a cover it's a call the
sack round and round with only one way
out a lot of nice houses on this street
highly covered real
estate no three
street called us sa by fear CK too CK by
fear in the community all right is now
she's now set to appear before judge
Joseph R demares which to me sounds like
a Looney Tunes character I'm Joseph R
demares I Own a Mansion and a
yacht you f me you may not
not I under ruled I love in the raccoon
send in the raccoon
B that was a great racon that's an
insane raccoon in West Morland County
Pennsylvania on May 25th for a
preliminary hearing uh dude if I'm her
I'm putting all this on my resume say I
took a gap here right I took a gap here
maybe she could like get a job writing
histories for American Girl dolls go
made it up we're going to figure this
out she's got a great
imagination so we don't know what
happened to her we don't know what the
sing was we don't this we don't know
that all this story but this is it
that's crazy that's how you do Story
number one down in the books another
dumb story where all you had to do was
communicate yeah totally just say like
uh I can't I can't finish college all
right even start it so let's take a
break we got Reggie Watts he's got a new
book out I'm so excited about excited
for him been following it all we're
going to let you know how to get it and
you can support this this young
gentleman right here and we'll tell you
what we have going on on the other side
Dan's going to tell you what Dan going
to tell we going on did are we doing
whoever does the first story does the
first plug did I not know that we didn't
know that all right we'll do all that on
the other side of the break it's Dum
people town with the great Reggie
Watts hello gentlemen and women we are
back and raccoons and raccoon there they
are reie wats is with us before we get
to his book I'm very excited about he
likes it do you ever see the video of
the guy with all the raccoons that are
like really FAL he just opens up a box
of cereal on his deck and they all crawl
all over him it's unbelievable I like
the one where the guy opens the dumpster
and they're all
like like yeah but then uh part two to
that some people have never seen it he
does just put up a big long like 2x4 and
one in and one out and they just all
crawl out one he doesn't leave them in
there but he just opens and there's like
15 raccoons going what I love that I
mean the are awesome the guy who rows
the seal I mean they're all fat so he
has literally fattened up a community of
raccoons and it's the greatest thing
it's not it can't be good for them no
it's def but they're happy or us dud
okay unless it's magic spoon and we
would love magic spoon to be a sponsor
sponsor sponsoring us I love mad so
before we get to Reggie's book we're
going to say for us uh come see us in
Cleveland we're doing shows at
hilarities which is an unbelievable Club
love that CL first and second December
everybody I love that
the best isn't it a great town like my
dad's from there people are up for
coming out and doing comedy big comedy
like Community there and fans there so I
love that place uh Portland at the
beginning of January and the next night
at Helium the next night at the
crocodile I love the Crocodile Seattle
crocod in the crocod and then at the
beginning of February we're in Denver at
Comedy Works South and the beginning of
uh March we're at the Mark Ridley's
Comedy Castle in Detroit beginning of
April we're in Minneapolis at Acme
Comedy these are all amazing clubs then
we're at moon tower with Daniel that's
going to be fun should be good would
love for that Happ make that happen and
then uh may we might even be in Alaska
so all that good stuff super.com check
it out we're manifesting it and uh
Reggie wats you have a new book please
let's let people know how to get it and
what it is sure it's a book it's out
it's uh on Amazon I guess great sure and
any bookstore so go to a go into your
local book book and purchase this you
know why because you'll go into the
store you'll buy like three or four of
them they'll be like we're low on the
Watts books yeah they'll reup got re up
on the watch what's it called yeah it's
called Uh Great Falls Montana uh Post
Punk weirdos and a tail or sorry Fast
Times postpunk weirdos and a tale of
coming home again oo that's awesome but
just Great Falls Montana real about your
youth yeah yeah my cuz I didn't know you
had one of it's about my UTS yeah but
does it you are you doing it from two
perspectives is that what the title
referen is like going home and viewing
it now or going home and looking back on
what it was like uh no it's more like uh
it's more chronological it's just it's
just describing my life you know from
being born in stutgart and then moving
around Europe and moving to Montana and
then going uh and then growing up in
Montana in 70s and ' 80s and then uh and
then it covers a little bit of when I
moved to Seattle in 1990 and a little
bit of New York and a little bit of LA
but it mostly centers around uh end of
Junior High through High School uh years
and you know all these stories about
yourself obviously but did you glean
something else when putting it all
together or you like cuz sometimes you
don't look at this and were you like oh
no wait a minute this is why I do this
because as you're starting to put all
these stories of your youth together and
say this is what my life was like in
Montana well you know what's funny it's
like it feels like I know all this stuff
I'm just explaining it to everybody else
like why why am I this thing it's like
well it's cuz of the these things right
basically musically in just general
you're the artist that you are what of
what you do like what do you attribute
to
Montana you know what I mean like
specifically yes the influence because
when you're in Europe and doing all that
I mean all of that musical influence and
all of that like how people are making
sounds and what's happening but I always
say people go well how do you know so
much country music and I'm like well
where I'm from there is three classic
rock stations four Christian stations
just walking in and out of gas
steni cars and school like that so it
become there where you're from like you
can have an influence that is maybe
people go yeah but you're this like I've
seen these Tik Tok really of Method Man
being like that's all the Beatles like
yeah I saw that yes it's and people of
course it [__] is and you for you
like what is the Montana influence I've
never been there and I've always wanted
to go there well I mean Montana you know
it's very similar to what you just
described Montana I mean it Great Falls
was you know it's about 65,000 people
it's an Air Force town so it's in in in
many ways it's one of the more
Cosmopolitan towns in Montana just
because you know and you're constantly
getting people moving in bringing in
from all over world yeah bringing in
their wives that they you know wives or
spouses that they' met in other
countries and so forth so you get this
mix of people not big but a little bit
of mix even like the teenagers you're
getting 16-year- olds and 17y olds who
just moved here from Chicago or from
South Carolina or something there was it
was kind of a transient is I mean you
know the basic like 80% stayed the same
but there was like a you know kind of a
transient 20% but I mean that we had you
know there was top 40 music and um uh
you know music elevator music and musac
and all those various things and then
plus TV and movies so I it was really
kind of the age of media you know kind
of the media explosion in the 80s
because movies got a little bit more
sophisticated multiplexes came into
being cable television expanded music TV
you saw it for the first time music TV
was like I mean MTV was insane because I
remember you know I always tell the
story of like when Michael Jackson's
Thriller came out I remember because
they were they they were playing it
every half an hour on MTV for an entire
day and I remember just getting out from
school couldn't wait for that clock to
you know to ring at 3:00 and I like
packed up all my stuff and I just
sprinted home to catch the next rotation
of that video so I mean that was like
mostly it and there was a lot of country
and you know there there was country
that I was EXP to in different ways um
it all kind of mixed together into this
kind of interesting world that I was
mimicking you took it all in that's the
thing is you took every single piece of
it and it like comes out in weird
hilarious ways when you're doing what
you're doing yeah I mean I will say that
some of when I I did shows in Montana
recently for the book tour and uh I just
spent so much time on like I was talking
about like people moving to like wanting
to move to Montana and I was like don't
move to Montana and I went on this big
thing I was like I was like they're like
like no but I really want to move it's
like well okay but do you do you know
how to chop wood do you know where to
store your wood you know you need to put
a tarp over your wood you know that's
better to store your wood here and I
just told you four things about wood
that you don't know you also just let me
see your pocket knife like I don't have
a pocket knife you're already out a
flashlight you have a flashlight in the
glove box do you have a flashlight that
you could drive your car over and not
break and you're gone don't [__] move
here you how put chains on your car do
you have gors do you have a Bas layer do
you have a b God damn layers a base
layer no one knows what that is if
you're not in a cold weather area you
haven't been in snow last thing and
we'll jump in did you audio book yeah
there's not a book yeah I didn't want to
do it but but I did I I did I was so
lazy I was like just have Fred armson do
it like I thought that would have been
funny they're just like what it's Fred
armson reading Reggie's you know what um
but I did it I'm glad I did it people
people were glad that it was me I mean
the of course it makes sense that it
would be me but I was very reticent for
no it's I'm thinking One Last Time title
so people can go out and get it yeah so
it's Reggie Watts Great Falls Montana uh
Post Punk weirdos oh sorry Fast Times
Post Punk weirdos and a tale of coming
home again available now in all local
book but if you have to order it on a
big place and have it come to you then
you know way or if you want to hear his
reluctance audible AUD his reluctance on
Audible uh of reading his own book uh
great stocking stuffer as the holidays
or we can now turn towards the holidays
and do it there support it all right you
guys ready for a yeah let do it yeah
let's do it this is sending by Brew
pounder at Brew pounder someone who
likes we're going to play a little round
of are they the [__] I love this so
at some point news became things that
happened on Tik Tok and posts on Reddit
so news became things happening between
two c like a couple that now everybody
gets to be like no he's the [__]
let's all weigh in on this people will
leave on the Reddit uh thread am I the
[__] and they'll tell their story and
then people weigh in yeah and then news
out let's go this is great for us today
we don't have enough to report on so
here we go a tenant we'll see we'll
check in with you guys see already hate
him I'm just kid has found himself in a
predicament after his landlord is
demanding fees from him that he is
technically not responsible for if the
man fails to pay the landlord his extra
money he faces a higher monthly rent
impossible we've all been rented even if
you don't pay they're going to go oh
we'll just raise your rent we've all
rented Apartments you have this weird
like employee boss relationship with
your landlord where you hate them
they're not nice but you got to kiss
their ass right so that's where he is
right now or you're in my scenario where
they're very nice and you still feel
guilty about everything that you ask
them for right and other people like
what's wrong with you I can't right
sharing his story to the subreddit am I
the [__] the man revealed that he is
currently renting out a basement Suite
in a family home let's not call it a
suite the suite is located next to a
laundry room mhm we all follow this
feels like I'm explaining clue yeah one
day a week one day a week the family
will unlock the door in the laundry room
that leads to my suite and I thus have
access to the room for the day I already
don't know if I think he's an [__]
for allowing himself to live this way or
they are for saying you you have one day
a week you can do do your laundry or we
don't trust you with our laundry machine
lock on the other door that accesses the
rest of the house put coins in the
laundry machine Jack and Joe laundry
room essentially so then he would have
access to their house technically
because their door the other door on the
other end of the laundry room like
everybody's an [__] in this way right
exactly but expecting somebody to be
like you live here you do your laundry
on Wednesdays if it's not a Wednesday TS
I'd be like [__] you I'm out but is this
something he also I get it you're to
your house what if I crap every pair of
underwear on a Monday you're in trouble
let me tell you how that goes but I mean
it's like did he does did he know that
when he was moving in that's that's the
difference must have had to show them
here's laund room you only have access
one he uses that yeah yeah yeah yeah I
love it cool cool deposit okay now let
me complain he uses this day to catch up
on all of his dirty laundry m i put my
clothes in the machine and shut the door
to the suite so that I don't hear all
that Ruckus sure so he enters their
laundry room washing a lot of sneakers I
get it then he shuts the door to his s
Suite which is normally locked but on
this day it's not MH okay there are
stairs that lead from the laundry room
to the rest the house so that the family
who owns the house can also access their
laundry room as well this guy's wife
gets murdered by an owl one day is this
are we talking about while the man was
doing his laundry uhoh and placed his
clothes in the dryer on his day he shut
the door sure went down the steps back
to his own they lock it he then heard
screams through the door screams the
next thing I know an ambulance has
arrived what apparently the landlord's
4-year-old son has somehow climbed into
the dve
while it was running and became trapped
inside obviously everyone this kid's
fine right no one knew how to get
according to the man the dryer is faulty
and does not shut off automatically when
the door is opened so in he shuts his
def the kid was wet we got got to drive
this kid out by wet I mean Drive enters
the laundry room from a door they never
locked cuz it accesses their own home
opens the dryer gets inside it doesn't
turn off no because the dryer he's
rolling around which is a big Fault in
Our Stars is he wearing a helmet no
honey what I say about getting in the
dry so the kid was tumbling in there a
while that's a very soft gener was
tumbling in
there get him get him it's like a ride
it's like a ride it's like a ride you he
Now does not have the ability if you're
not going to use your words I'm not
going to take you out yeah what are you
trying to say you say no let him say it
David don't he has to say it he has to
say it within 30 rotations he's got 30
rotations to say it or he's
done so the kid was in there tumbling
for a while and the door was open all
because the machine didn't shut itself
off when the door was open thankfully
after a trip to the hospital the child
turned out to be fine although he was
released with a hefty medical bill a
medical bill that the man's landlords
now expect their tenant to cover since
the laundry since it was his laundry
that their son climbed into that
is you are not watching your kids it's
all on you no parents you're a bad
parent if you let me say this right now
they want him to pay the bill where's my
camera tell you right now if you are a
parent and your kid does something dumb
and your first instinct is to blame
someone else you're not a good parent
that's right you are you're BL you
immediately blame your kids and you walk
you get up and you go what did he do I'm
sorry what did he and then based on how
good they are with a response that is
either a lie or the truth you then
assess your current if your kid goes to
you nothing I didn't do anything I saw
you climbing his thing he pulled me into
the dryer all right now we have a story
now we have something we have to
investigate he pulled you in the dryer
now I got to find out if he did it or
not my first instinct is what did you do
what did you do I'm just I'm just
imagining like this parent like they're
in the kitchen and like the kid like has
like those like whatever garlic whatever
those little hand mallets for like
tenderizing meat or whatever he like
hits his hand and he turns around he's
like okay who's responsible for this
yeah who can we Sue who did this who can
I place blame on for this it's the Tim
Robinson sketch we all want to find out
who drove the hot dog car into
this so here's the deal the family would
say you owe of me money for my kid I
would go it why and like it was your
laundry and I would go it's your dry
right and they go yeah but it was your
laundry I go he opened the door you own
right can't we get together Su the
laundry Su the dryer company I thought
you were just say the laundry itself can
we sue the dirty cloth soe the clothes
it's actually there's a prent for that
is since the family people versus Dirty
Laundry who owns the home does not have
medical insurance the ambulance and
hospital bills that they are asking
their tenant to pay totals how much
money oh my
$62,000 oh my God that's not crazy by
the way no I think 13 they give you
insurance bill numbers 137 $113,700 it
said Hefty bill yeah 24,000 okay the
cost that they want their tenant to pay
is
8,47 still a lot still a lot that's
still you're living in a basement of
someone else's family and you're having
to call that a sweet you don't have
eight large sitting around do you think
that like one of the parents said to the
other one like well maybe we
get him to pay and then the other parent
who's equally as dumb was like yeah yes
we can yeah he it's his laundry then
they start they don't have insurance to
cover this no they're they're
they're laundry the man argues I mean
they're laundering kids it's a money
laundering situ it's a money laundering
situation responsibility can we also
bring back the word large for $1,000
every time you do that think large I
think it's going to cost you 50 large
three large how much was that it got
replaced with rack large large got
replaced with racks and G's well yeah
G's forever G's forever but like one
rack is 10g large rack yeah it's from
poker oh okay a rack okay however the
man argues he's not responsible for
paying the medical bills and for and for
valid reasons he says quote I am not in
charge of watching their kid I am paying
an insane amount of rent well that
really
doesn't other issue sneak that in there
I didn't agree to babysit anyone in a
addition to living there it is their
laundry machine that is par apparently
faulty like he starts in this article
getting I don't say anything when they
fight getting a divorce like like okay
sir I don't complain about them smelling
like cumin up there Hey listen human I
don't uh I don't complain about the fact
that I know I get a third of my packages
we're like what does that have to do
with still the man's landlords are
insisting that he covered their son's
medical expenses now he is turning to
wherever he can for advice on handling
the situation I went to a forum that was
oriented towards landlords to see if I
was really responsible you talk about
the landlord form yeah which is just a
Facebook group come on let's not get
[__] fancy I mean I there are many
times I'll often turn to should we get
dinner before or after the landlord
check the land landord forms on he was
ask on I DVR it and I won't be home for
the end so do not tell me hey are you
free Thursday night are you free
Thursday at 8 what's to 8 Thursday I've
got landlord for him you got landlord
for him that's 8 is the only time this
it's just the worst PBS
show landlord for landord like eight
landlords just like disgusting like
landlords for a city no one lives in I
want to put up a retaining wall anyway
uh he was asked if the family he lived
with Ever Raised his rent and he
admitted they had not after he had lived
in their space for nearly a year and a
half they wouldn't it's a year maybe a
year but even still kudos to them for
not raising it I pay my rent on time
every time and don't cause a problem
other than
I assume them not collecting a little
extra is still better than the risk of
trying to find
a so bad sounds like you let mey me let
me dry your kid for five minutes let me
just dry your kid if someone said I want
to dry your kid you you yank them away
so fast but also Imagine as parents you
guys you know you do the you do the
thing when they get you're okay you're
okay you're okay you don't have any
wrinkles look at your hair you're okay
it's so fluffy static like he was nice
enough to throwy he's got like three
socks stuck don't have a big reaction
until he has a reaction yeah exactly
guys before you get mad I'm just going
to say he's okay okay just let me see
him no it's okay uh just just just hold
on the guy who took him out before the
parents okay there you go yeah you look
good okay you look good stand over there
he's fine where is he he's fine do not
answer my question so dry where is he's
so dry he's the dest oh I imagine the
guy if the I had found him first okay
don't be mad to the parents where is he
but he's still in there but I wanted to
make sure you're not mad at me don't be
mad he's going to smell like bounce for
like about a year so just so you know I
took video um of him you know rolling
around in there just so you get like an
idea of what that was like um we're
making a lot of money on reels right
now uh we're live streaming just you
know uh okay so we all agree they're the
[__] for
sure he he's a little bit of a wet
blanket
the
Dr all right let's take a break when we
come back uh is it us or you it's you
it's Daniel Danel his uh dates and uh
and we have a story about uh the most
dangerous karaoke ever I cannot wait
Reggie Watts is with us he's got a new
book Reggie Watts if you just look up
Reggie Watts Montana Falls you will find
not Montana Falls I mean it's close gra
Falls fall no it's close it's close it's
close you'll find it it's close if you
you would at least get a did mean did
you here dummy that's that's like the
new thing it's like did you means like
cuz it like it's more engagement right
yeah but that would beun how did you get
that would be a funny thing to do in
life to like correct people oh yeah and
be like uh yeah yeah I I think did you
mean is the most passive aggressive way
of being like correcting someone yeah
did you Someone Like You It's like how
the English do the thing at the end yeah
it's not that hard though is
ity rhetorical at the end and you're
like wait am I answering this question
kind like this don't you all right with
all that we're going to find Bad karaoke
on the other side the break it's dumb
people town with the regs we'll be right
[Music]
back hey guys I want to talk about our
engagement process like when how we got
engaged and I it's like two decades ago
for us I wish jamesallen.com was around
same for us back then I had to go
through a guy who knew a guy and I'm
looking at sort of and you're in the
store and you're like is this dude
upselling me on this stuff and he's
trying to get a commission my eyesight I
don't know how to look at something
through a loop it was just weird I need
it magnified for me I'm not an expert
well jamesallen.com thankfully they make
it easy and fun choose from over 200,000
certified conflict-free diamonds that's
important and they've got both Earth
created and lab created yeah once you
pick your diamond you see it in a MAG
magnified 360° view that's amazing what
the actual Diamond looks like up close
in HD on your phone on your comp you can
broadcast that to your TV and see it
even bigger you pick from hundreds of
ring settings in Platinum white gold
rose gold yellow go they got everything
you need for you they make it easy the
process is simp how about this
everything from James Allen comes with a
lifetime warranty free resizing free
resizing you know I had to get my ring
resized like three times after C
certainly for your wife if she gets
pregnant like your hands CH you need to
resize and Engraving and hassle-free
30-day returns I love these guys so
right now you get 25% off your order
when you go to jamesallen.com use the
code DPT that's DPT jamesallen.com for
25% off 4 and percent James allen.com
Jay let's talk about fairity I have so
many fairity pieces of clothing in my
Arsenal every time I wear it people are
like where'd you get that I got this
rugby shirt by the them that reminds me
of the 1980s is the most comfortable
shirt I've ever purchased where you've
worn it on stage the last couple fits
well it looks great so that's the thing
about fairity clothes not only do they
look good they have amazing colors
really cool patterns that you know are
like flannels that are stretchy almost
like sweaters in their Legend sweater
colle and all all their stuff is
comfortable I bought stuff for my
daughter there I bought a pullover Fleet
you have that pullover fleece pullover
fleece and I just got it's not a
pullover it's a zip up fleece and it's
beautiful with a great sort of
interesting sort of Native American
design on it but I just got two Blazers
from them incredible Blazers that are
just fit so perfectly I chino pants that
are light and they stretch it's amazing
their clothes are amazing th this is a
company started by twin brothers who we
love these guys are great I'm so happy
to see them growing as a company and I'm
so grateful that they're sponsoring this
podcast they will become your favorite
pieces of clothes that you wear faity is
giving our friends at Dum people town
our townies listeners and amazing deal
that's 20% off your order head to faity
brand.com DPT use the code DPT a
checkout that's F A rty brand.com
DPT support these guys CU they support
us they understand what it's like to be
kind of independent and doing their
thing and they're succeeding and so are
we I love these guys fairity brand.com
DPT sck
around hey gang welcome back to the show
before we get into our final story The
before we get into dancing I have to
tell Reggie do it my happy place is
watching was it Reggie makes music yes
the little Clips you would do from uh oh
ComEd from Comedy Bang Bang saibi you
and rashita Jones oh yeah the thing you
guys did yeah I will play that for
myself to feel calm and happy it's one
of the most beautiful things I've ever
heard improvised yeah you guys were just
improvising I keep listening to it and I
love it thank you for doing that and it
was probably something you're like did I
do that when did I do that I mean it's
like you did so much I mean rashita
Jones you can't not forget that that was
really special you guys together I mean
the music you made was beautiful any
thanks I'm just uh December 14th Cap
City comedy club and then go to
daniel.com I think I'm going to be doing
a run of the Pacific Northwest and if
there's any dates I haven't hit on the
rose gold tour tell me where you want me
to come I might do Florida all by
oh my
God that is
incredible do the
dip hurricane of Comedy yep let me know
Daniel vk.com speaking of Florida we're
going there all right let's do it on
this last story Florida uh this sent in
by Andy the G or we like to call him
little Andy Greenberg little Andy
Greenberg brever man this is the
headline County brever County I love
that in Florida there's Broward County
and BR County it's like they forgot what
are we going going to name this I don't
know one sounds like you're saying the
other but drunk this is our buddy Eric
fredman had a great joke he was driving
along in LA and oh out like in by the
beach he saw a street that was just
called
nrose that's the dumbest thing ever what
are we going to call this Melrose no
there's already a Mose I don't know call
it nrose that's like my Aunt Nell we
used to joke with her it's like she's
like nrose she's so fancy
butrose over here so BR County the
Brewer the Broward County of Florida the
brever man wields machete at bar no
after karaoke request denied deputies
say makes sense though I I would he want
to sing I would yeah I would need to
know s let's hear what he wanted to sing
a brever Connie man accused of pulling a
how long machete how many inches was
this S 2 foot oh 24
in
Machete it's like an anime character
it's like from the movie Sword I think
it's 36 in an 18in machete wow like that
here at a bar after being denied another
karaoke song so he had already done one
know I need to go again uh was arrested
Sunday according to the Sheriff's Office
de I think it really has to do with the
song CU if it's a song that everybody
wants to hear everybody's going to be
like let him do it let him do it yeah
like if if he can Crush Lately by JY let
him do it if he can Crush I want to sex
you up by color me bad
that's all right let me take off all
your clothes disconnect the phone so
nobody knows that's so romantic yeah all
right so this guy's name is Travis
Jordan I'm not going to tell you how old
he is TJ he faces a breach of Peace due
to disorderly conduct uh chargeing
connection with also killing the
vibe which occurred at Kennedy's Lamp
Post Tavern look love that place I'll
tell you it's located on 7822 North
Atlantic Avenue in Cape Canaveral where
we've launched
manyet many a rocket into space Cape
Canaveral so we launched that rocket go
over to the kenned Kennedy's lamp lamp
post tab by the way so Cape Canaveral
Kennedy Space Center this is all making
sense guy could work for NASA and he
could just be like drunk dick engineer
type yes mission control like Mission
too much control so the deputies respond
to the bar shortly after what time or
sorry shortly before what time 400 p.m.
M oh it's late at night I'm going to go
1:00 a.m. uh 9:30 get your answers in
before 2 2 p.m.
2m. on a Sunday okay man this is that's
your problem for starting karaoke too
early they found you can't do K light
out people aren't even finishing brunch
no brunch yoke you can't do that uh
found Jordan unsteady on his feet with
bloodshot and glassy eyes Travis Jordan
or Michael Jordan um smelling strongly
of alcohol and probably cause
David show Deputy spoke with a person
who said Jordan pulled out the machete
which was concealed on his body after
someone denied his request to sing
another karaoke song The Woman afraid
for the safety of others coed the
suspect into peacefully handing over the
machete wow if drop it drop it drop it
if he would do drop it if she would do a
duet of endless love with him yeah yeah
or she or she's just like oh my God what
who who makes that M kiss see that real
quick
M oh my God that is I have one just like
wow you are the King of Wishful Thinking
that's I'll get over I they don't say
the song
and put in the affidavit a member of the
bar staff then hid the weapon and we
need to hold that over we're going to
put this over here all I'm just saying
is this guy showed up to Afternoon
karaoke Mach with a machete like idiot I
better get my songs or else that's czy
and the law enfor said everyone started
freaking out when he oh thought going to
say Kung that was who admitted Jordan
who admitted to wielding the weapon told
deputies he was it was me he was
threatened days prior and had to stay
alert to protect himself oh you're a
grudge guy okay but he had not been in
danger the night he P maybe it was 2:
a.m. they said the night he pulled out
the machete Aid David show I was just
talking with him yeah I was gesticulate
a lot with my glasses and I had I forgot
it was in my hand do you want to guess
the rating of The Bar Kennedy's Lamp
Post Tavern 4.6 out of out of five out
of five stars
477 4.6 stars is the lamp post what do
you think I going to say
4.2 three
3.9
4 zero oh I said you one off yeah yeah
there we go damn yeah they need work all
right let's get out of here on this how
I wish I knew the song I wish it was WAP
I wish it was Endless Love I wish it was
well [__] and Endless Love are basically
the same song they really are endless
love that's a huge That's Heavy That's
Heavy a heavy song reunited oh my gosh
Come on Islands in the Stream in the
Stream can we talk oh my gosh uh Shake
You Down by Gregory Abbott well you too
that's your Higher by Creed yeah Higher
Love by Winwood baby there you go okay
oh my God how old is he how old is
Travis don't call me Michael
jordan1 wielding a weapon Florida if it
is daytime angry that angry that early
in the day that is old a lot of
bitterness yeah but I will
go 26 47 I knew it a good guess though I
say 26
4761 get your answers was my locker
combination in high school go see Daniel
at Cap City in the middle of December
come see us in Cleveland all the all the
while you're buying Reggie's book and
you're supporting giving it as a gift
for your friends who you love holiday
gift Travis Jordan Great Falls machete
in the pants 39 years old oh that was
close we all kind of had an idea you all
were kind of right in a weird way older
than you think older than you think
pushing 40 older should know better than
to carry a machete yes but not like
crazy old so Dan was kind of right and
then we all were kind of right 39 is
where you can start just like what are
we doing man tur Point what are we doing
here man like a younger guy you're like
we're going to have to tackle we're to
39 you're like is it going you really
mad at potential card starts going away
at9 medicine think of your kids were
here man I know that's right all right
there you go that's the show that's how
we attack the dumb in this world with
the great Reggie Watts I love that
you're here man thank you so much
Namaste International Namaste everybody
and oh [__] we got to get back to
work sck around make sound there's more
to
[Music]
oh